[Música]
[Aplausos]
bueno buenos días a todos muchísimas
gracias por estar acá
hace un tiempo que tengo una idea y hoy
me voy a animar a contarse las ustedes
hoy vengo a reflexionar con ustedes
sobre la sociedad que vivimos sobre
nuestra sociedad sobre esta sociedad
una sociedad que a mi manera de ver se
encuentra en una grave crisis una crisis
política una crisis social y una crisis
económica
crisis política que se pone de
manifiesto en la falta de próceres en la
falta de estadistas
en la falta de un líder de valores a
quien seguir
crisis social que la vemos en la
cantidad de movimientos sociales de
organizaciones sociales que a lo largo
ya lo ancho del país levantan diferentes
banderas sin ponerse de acuerdo en qué y
una crisis económica vaya si sabemos los
argentinos de una crisis económica
una crisis económica que nos lleva a
tener diferentes eventos solidarios
basta con abrir el diario prender la
tele agarrar una revista para ver cena
solidaria en la rural para juntar fondos
para desayuno solidario para colecta
solidaria para el equipo de barrio en tu
club barrio seguramente están
organizando un bingo solidario para
comprar
y acá viene la primera definición que
quiero tomar con ustedes qué significa
ser solidario
qué significa ser solidario cómo podemos
definir una persona solidaria
había definición una persona solidaria
es aquella que realiza la acción de dar
de compartir
generalmente es un bien puede ser dinero
puede ser ropa puede ser un juguete en
fin las personas solidarias dan y
comparten lo que pueden lo que tienen y
créanme está bien ser solidario se lo
repito está bien ser solidario pero
alcanza con ser solidario para cambiar
los tres problemas que tiene nuestra
sociedad
quien acá me puede decir cuál es la
diferencia entre la persona solidaria y
una persona generosa
a propósito ya saben por qué una gira
atrás mío nada tiene que ver con el
famoso punto
nada tiene que ver
y repensemos quien acá sabe cuál es la
diferencia entre una persona solidaria y
una persona generosa
bueno una persona solidaria como les
dije es aquella que algo que puede lo
que tiene lo que le sobra
y una persona generosa y una persona
generosa
una persona generosa da lo que puede lo
que tiene y lo que le cuesta
le pone a la acción de compartir de dar
es a ese sacrificio y qué es lo que más
te cuesta a votarle a ella
qué es lo que más nos cuesta a nosotros
compartir
nuestro tiempo
lo que más nos cuesta compartir en
nuestro tiempo es poner mi tiempo al
servicio del otro en wikipedia
definición de persona generosa
persona que realiza la acción noble de
dar y compartir y ejemplifica en
momentos de desastres naturales personas
que ponen su tiempo y habilidad momento
hay que llegar a un desastre natural
para ser generosos
no
pero me gustó la parte de pone su tiempo
y habilidad pone su tiempo y lo que sabe
hacer
y qué pasaría si en lugar de ser
solidarios empezamos a ser generosos
qué pasaría si en lugar de ser una
sociedad de personas solidarias fuésemos
una sociedad de personas generosas
qué pasaría si en lugar de dar lo que
puedo lo que tengo y lo que me sobra
empiezo a dar lo que me cuesta
qué pasaría si en lugar de tener
políticos que vayan a una cena solidaria
tuviésemos políticos generosos
ya lo ven sus caras algo está cambiando
miren hace un tiempo tuvo una utopía
tuve una visión y se está cumpliendo
me preguntaba qué pasaría si los 300.000
alumnos que tiene la uva tuviesen para
poder retirar su título de grado
tuviesen que realizar 50 horas 50 horas
nada más a lo largo de la carrera 50
horas de práctica social obligatoria
qué pasaría si los 300.000 alumnos de la
uva tuviesen que poner su tiempo y su
habilidad su tiempo y lo que saben para
ayudar a otros
ya estaríamos formando 300 mil alumnos
generosos
ahora dígame qué pasaría si todos los
alumnos del sistema universitario ya sea
público o privado tuviesen que realizar
50 horas 10 sábados de 5 horas poniendo
su tiempo
y su habilidad y su conocimiento al
servicio de otros
ya está pasando ya estamos cambiando
miren del año 2007 2017 esta universidad
decreto que es obligatorio para retirar
el título de grado realizar una práctica
social educativa obligatoria esta
universidad decretó que todos los
alumnos que rece que deseen obtener un
título de la uba tienen que revisar 50
horas de práctica social 50 horas
poniendo su tiempo y su habilidad en
favor de los que más lo necesitan acá
está pasando estos son alumnos de
odontología de agronomía de veterinaria
que dejaron la comodidad de su casa el
afecto de su novia de su familia para
poner su habilidad y su tiempo al
servicio de las poblaciones más
vulnerables al servicio de lo que más lo
necesitan
qué va a pasar cuando todos qué va a
pasar cuando todos dejemos de ser
solidarios y empecemos a ser generosos
miren les aseguro muchos de estos
alumnos para hacer los políticos del
mañana
muchos de estos alumnos van a dejar de
ser solidarios para pasar a ser
generosos
me quiero despidiendo
pero le voy a dejar tres reflexiones
la primera
juancar fundación de la red solidaria
varía la redundancia juancar dijo
hay que pasar de la emoción al
compromiso sostenido
se lo repito hay que pasar de la emoción
al compromiso sostenido
me mueve la frase juan cartel de
agregaría un par de palabras
hay que pasar de la emoción de dar
al compromiso sostenido de hacer
hay que pasar de la emoción de dar lo
que puede lo que me sobra al compromiso
sostenido de poner mi tiempo y habilidad
para los que más lo necesitan
miren hace 2000 años vivió el mejor
psicoanalista que tuvo nuestra historia
hace 2000 años vivió el mejor
psicoanalista le sitúa en esta historia
y dijo rico no es el que más tiene sino
el que menos necesita ya saben de quién
estoy hablando rico no es el que más
tiene sino el que menos necesita hay que
dejar de para nosotros y empezar a mirar
un poco en el otro hay que empezar a
poner nuestro tiempo y habilidad en
ayudar a los que más lo necesitan
atrás mío está el fiel reflejo de la
social argentina
y no con su genial más falda y susanita
tres imágenes serás acordé un poco más
falda le contaba a susanita sobre los
problemas sobre un problema grande y
susanita le decía
tenemos la culpa a nosotros y se
contestaba hacia vida no podemos hacer
algo para solucionar este problema no lo
único que podemos hacer es decir qué
barbaridad
cuadrito siguiente que hace susanita qué
barbaridad último cuadro miren la cara
más falda susanita elipse dale decimos
también qué barbaridad así nos vamos a
jugar y nos olvidamos este problema
bueno está asociada al pasado la de
papas hoy somos una sociedad solidaria
yo les propongo que seamos una sociedad
generosa me despido gracias por su
tiempo y quiero decirles algo está bien
ser solidario está muy bien ser
solidario pero está mucho mejor ser
generosos chau
[Aplausos]
ah
[Música]